[Music]
hi i'm dylan beatty i'm going to be at
ndc oslo later this year teaching my
workshop at introduction to
distributedsystemswith.net
it's aimed at developers with a bit
of.net experience who are interested in
understanding more about how to design
and build distributed systems
over two days of deep dive hands-on
training we'll look at all the most
common architectural patterns for
connecting components and services we're
gonna look at rest graphql message
queues publish subscribe i'm gonna look
at grpc which is great for building fast
lightweight distributed components uh
also for connecting.net code to apps
running on python and node.js other
platforms like that and we're going to
plug in signalr we're going to create
some real-time web notifications so when
something happens somewhere in one of
your backend microservices you can pop
up a real-time web notification showing
your users what just happened
you're going to be writing and running
code throughout the workshop uh bring a
laptop with a recent version of.net so
net core 2.2 uh framework 4.6 or of
course.net 5. any of those will work
but we're not just going to be writing
code we're going to talk about it as
well talk you know why do these
different patterns and protocols exist
what kind of problems were they designed
to solve uh when does it make sense to
use them in your your own applications
we're going to look at testing
monitoring logging security all the kind
of stuff you need to know beyond just
how to make it work on your machine and
we'll have plenty of time for questions
and discussion and live demos and stuff
plus it's ndc we've got three days of
amazing speakers sessions panel
discussions everything else that makes
ndc such a great event to be part of
that's all at nbc oslo 29th of november
to the 3rd of december the oslo spectrum
live in person
it'd be great to see you there check it
out at nbcoslow.com
[Music]